Heartbroken Spider-Man fans have received
a little fatherly wisdom to help ease the
pain.
Dominic Holland, comedian, author, and father
of Spidey actor Tom Holland, recently took
to his blog to offer up his thoughtful take
on the prospect of the beloved character potentially
exiting the Marvel Cinematic Universe following
an impasse between Marvel Studios and rights
holder Sony Pictures.
The elder Holland reminded fans in his August
21st post that they likely haven't seen the
last of his son's Spidey, and that in the
end, the factor which likely precipitated
the split will be the same one that ensures
that their favorite hero returns to the screen:
money.
"My eldest son is owned by the world now,
but he's kinda still my little lad and I have
to look after him."
Holland explained that he'd been asked for
his take on the situation by multiple media
outlets, but had politely declined.
For his blog's readers, however, he felt compelled
to comment, and he betrayed just a touch of
scorn for the big Hollywood power players
who had failed to get a new deal done for
the fans, writing,
"I have no inside track on such issues.
But whatever is decided by the big suits at
these big Hollywood studios my hunch is that
the show will continue.
Too much at stake and too many dollars riding
on it and besides, everyone wants the same
thing; namely, Spider-Man on large screens
keeping people safe and entertained.
And with Tom in the suit, for the time-being
at least.
And in the years ahead, no doubt, with another
lucky young actor in the role."
Just a day later, the self-described "friendly,
neighborhood father of Tom Holland" felt the
need to clarify his statement due to the deluge
of headlines which followed his initial post.
He wrote that he held no animosity towards
either party, and he appeared slightly irked
at the possibility that such misrepresentations
of his comments could reflect poorly on his
son, writing,
"As I said in the post…
'I know nothing' and my only speculation remains,
that Spider-Man will go on saving people and
keeping us all entertained.
In fact, Tom Holland's dad has not even spoken
with Tom Holland since this seismic story
broke and he certainly is not taking any sides,
he is not calling for any boycotts and he
will not be storming any offices anytime soon.
These headlines are just click bait.
A salacious headline to create website traffic."
Holland closed with a pointed parting shot
at those who would twist his words for clicks,
followed by a bit of characteristically British
self-effacing humor.
The elder Holland wrote,
"[The misrepresentation] is shameful and not
something I would ever stoop to until I consider
that I posted a blog on the subject knowing
that it might increase traffic to my site…
So, am I any better?
Maybe not.
But I am not so stupid that I would ever do
anything to compromise my family and involving
myself in something so far above my pay grade
immediately springs to mind."
Spider-Dad is certainly taking the high road
here, and so far, his son has had no comment
on the matter.
He's continued to post on social media without
making any mention of the split but if comments
he's made previously are any indication, he's
probably not too psyched about it.
Consider Holland's words when asked about
the possibility of his Spider-Man meeting
up with Tom Hardy's Venom, whose adventures
take place in the wholly distinct Sony Universe
of Marvel Characters, in 2017.
"You know, I'd love to make a movie with Tom
Hardy, and if we ever got the chance to make
a Venom movie together, that would be super
cool.
But his movie would have to take place in
the MCU, because I'm not giving up my ticket."
Well, Tom, it sadly appears that you may not
have a choice.
But it also appears that your dear old Dad
raised you well, because you appear to be
approaching the situation with the same level
head that he is.
It's a delicate matter, and immediately going
public with ill-chosen, poorly thought-out
words would be… well, irresponsible.
And as we all know, with great power comes
great responsibility.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.